[MUSIC PLAYING]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Hi.
And welcome to episode number
47 of the weekly Google Cloud
Platform Podcast.
I am Francesc Campoy.
And I'm here with my
colleague, Mark Mandel.
Hey Mark.
How are you doing?
MARK MANDEL: I'm good.
Thanks, Fransesc.
How are you doing?
We're in a slightly
different room today.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
I think people will be able to
hear a little bit of the echo
unless you do an amazing
job with the editing.
MARK MANDEL: That's unlikely.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
So probably you'll
be hearing some echo.
That is because someone
broke the door in our studio.
So we cannot enter.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Things happen.
MARK MANDEL: That's fine.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Anyway.
So today, we're going to
be interviewing two people
from the Cloud Abuse team, Swati
Kulshreshth and Emeka Okonkwo.
I hope I didn't completely
mispronounce your names.
And they're going to
be telling us about
what is Cloud Abuse,
why you should care,
and basically, how Cloud Abuse
is here to protect you also.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
I think this was
really kind of cool.
It is a really
interesting conversation.
And why you should care
as a customer of GCP
about why this group exists.
It's not there to
get in your way.
It's there to really help you.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
Actually, it's also to
protect people outside
of Google Cloud Platform too,
which is an interesting thing.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
After that, we have our question
of the week, where we go back
to Kubernetes, one of my
favorite topics, where
we look at easy ways to deploy
well-known applications.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
it's basically a mix
of your two favorite topics.
Deployment manager
in Kubernetes,
is there such a thing?
So very interesting.
Before that, we're going
to go with the cool thing
of the week.
Cool things of the week.
And we have four today.
Two of them are really tiny.
So the first one is about
dataset, new dataset
available on Google Cloud,
which is public geo dataset.
So basically, a bunch of images
from all around the world.
And if you've listened
to all of our episodes,
this might sound familiar.
It is actually the same dataset
that Descartes Labs, which
we interviewed in
episode 41, has
been using for quite a while.
There's a bunch of images.
They're really cool, actually.
I know in the blog post, which
we will link from the show
notes, there's a bunch
of images that we even
used in some of the show
notes for episode 41.
And some really nice
pictures of Australia.
MARK MANDEL: Well, as
long as it's Australia,
that's what's important.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
It's a place called Brisbane.
I don't know.
MARK MANDEL:
Brisbane's pretty nice.
I've been there.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I've
never been there.
I'd love to.
No.
Looks like there's
nice pictures.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
There is.
And speaking of open datasets,
there's another open dataset
that I think is also really
cool, the Open Images Dataset.
So it consists of
approximately 9 million URLs
to images that
have been annotated
with the labels spanning
about 6,000 categories.
So if you want to get
some image data that you
want to put through
machine learning
and tag it very similarly to
how Google Photos or the Cloud
Vision API works,
you can do that.
So you can actually do some
really neat stuff with it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
I think that
basically, if you have
all of these pictures
with all the annotations,
and then you want to started
playing with TensorFlow,
this could be a really
nice place to basically,
can you try to emulate
the Cloud Vision API?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
I actually think it
could be cool as well
in that you could dig into
specific categories of stuff.
Like say you want to be
able to work out, say,
what metal maybe
cutlery is made out of.
So you grab everything that is
cutlery and then kind of break
it down from there.
You could do some
really interesting stuff
as a starting point
for machine learning.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
I'm actually seeing
the picture of the cutlery.
I have no idea
what metal that is.
MARK MANDEL: I don't know.
That's why I saw the image too
and I was like, hm, cutlery.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
That's a good point.
MARK MANDEL: But
something like that could
be really interesting.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
That sounds like
something I could try.
And then there's
two more cool things
of the week, which are
completely self promotion
because I'm shameless.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
So Fransesc, if you had
a podcast, in theory,
and you wanted to get that
podcast to go onto YouTube,
how would you do such a thing?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That's a very
interesting question, Mark.
So we actually did this.
As we announced a
couple weeks ago,
we actually have all
of our podcast episodes
available on YouTube.
And this was done automatically
because it is easier.
Well, it is actually not easier,
but I do not hate my life.
So basically what this is,
it's a Docker container
will download some MP3
files from an RSS feed
and publish everything
to YouTube, adding
one image that you can choose.
And the news is that it
just has been open sourced.
So you can go to
github.com/campo
y/podcasttoyoutube
and just check it out.
And then I also open sourced
something else last week,
which is a Go Web Workshop.
And it's basically
the basics on how
to build web applications
using Go on App Engine.
So if you're curious
to learn how I normally
do it, on the front end side
of things, it's super light.
So don't expect to learn
anything about CSS3 or HTML5.
It is actually pretty bad.
But we don't care because
it is about the back end.
So you will learn about how
to use Datastore and Memcache,
and how to send emails
and stuff like that.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
Sounds great.
Well, why don't we have a
chat with Swati and Emeka
and talk to them
about Cloud Abuse?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
Let's do that.
So I'm very happy to welcome
to the podcast two members
of the Cloud Abuse team.
So we have Swati Kulshreshth.
How are you doing?
SWATI KULSHRESHTH: Hi.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
And Emeka Okonkwo.
Hi.
EMEKA OKONKWO:
Pleasure to meet you.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: How
are you both doing?
SWATI KULSHRESHTH: Good.
Good.
EMEKA OKONKWO: Yeah.
It's nice to meet you guys.
MARK MANDEL: Well
done, Fransesc.
Those are two tricky names.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I know.
It's my specialty.
But then I mess it up with
completely English-sounding
names.
[LAUGHTER]
So why don't we start talking
a little bit about who you are,
what you do at Google.
Maybe start with you, Swati.
SWATI KULSHRESHTH: Sure.
So I'm part of the Cloud
Trust and Safety Team.
And what our team does
is basically protect
the cloud from abuse
originating from Google Cloud.
I specifically look at
the developer experience
associated with that.
EMEKA OKONKWO: And I work
as a senior strategist
on the same team.
And again, the mission is to
protect folks against abuse
from cloud.
MARK MANDEL: OK.
Cool.
So we said "abuse" a
few times through that.
What does cloud
abuse actually mean?
Emeka, why don't you go first?
EMEKA OKONKWO: Sure.
So cloud abuse, the
way it's defined,
is any kind of
activity that ends up
violating the cloud terms of
services or acceptable user
policy.
So our team's goal,
or mission, is
to basically enforce the
relevant sections of the cloud
terms of services/AUP.
MARK MANDEL: Could
you give a couple
examples of what kind
of terms of services
that you normally handle?
EMEKA OKONKWO: Sure.
So things such as,
like, denial of terms
attacks that emanate from the
cloud platform, or intrusion
attacks, or even
malware or phishing.
Those kind of activities
are the things
that we are responsible for
protecting or preventing.
SWATI KULSHRESHTH:
And to add to that,
the things that would
violate the terms of service,
like you're going beyond
your quota restrictions
or doing things that
you shouldn't be doing,
given the cloud services
that you're using.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
And so you're saying that
basically, what you're doing
is not protecting Google
Cloud Platform customers
from external abuse, but
actually stopping abuse coming
from Google Cloud Platform.
SWATI KULSHRESHTH:
That is exactly right.
Our team is focused on looking
at abuse that originated
from the Google Cloud Platform.
And that is the kind of
activity that we specifically
look for and try to stop.
EMEKA OKONKWO: Attacks
that come to Google
is handled by Site
Reliability Engineers.
So that's a different team.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
We've talked with
a couple of them.
We should keep on talking
with more of them.
They're always so
cool to talk to.
MARK MANDEL: OK.
So clearly, the people who
listen to our podcasts,
they're responsible people.
They're wonderful people.
We love them dearly.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
They're listeners.
MARK MANDEL: They're listeners.
So clearly, they're great.
They're not going to actively
go out and try and do
things that are
malicious or nefarious
or something like that.
Why should they care
about Cloud Abuse?
Is there issues in
terms of resources?
What sort of problems is
this solving for people
who are customers of GCP?
SWATI KULSHRESHTH: So
there are two of abuse
we see coming from Google Cloud.
There's intentional abuse.
And clearly, like you said, your
listeners are not one of those.
But then there is the
unintentional abuse.
You did not want to be
conducting denial of service
attempts or intrusion attempts.
But your system has
been hacked or there's
software that you
downloaded, and that
is doing it on your behalf.
And those are the kinds of
things that we are looking for.
And those are the kind
of things that you
should be looking at too.
EMEKA OKONKWO: And
to add on to that,
it could be possible
that, for example,
if someone hacks your
system-- so again,
that's a breach on your system.
You really don't want to
be responsible for that.
Or at least, you want to
find out as soon as possible
if that happens.
Or if someone is
using your machine
to perform a denial
of terms attack,
that could cost a lot
of money on the cloud,
so a lot of computing
resources that you
would have to be
responsible for paying for.
So hopefully, if we
catch that in time,
that will be very
awesome for you.
And also, finally, if you
have an external website that
is hosted somewhere,
we are trying
to protect you from being hit
by people who are on cloud.
So makes life better
for everybody.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
I'm curious-- you mentioned
denial of service attacks.
What other kinds of use
cases do you normally see?
Is it people getting
infected with some bots?
What kind of problem
that you normally handle?
EMEKA OKONKWO: So we see a lot
of denial of terms attacks.
We also see a lot of
brute forcing activities.
So basically, once
a machine maybe
is hacked-- because of
course, none of our users
are going to do it.
So a compromised
machine could be
trying to probe vulnerabilities
against external networks.
So trying to maybe log
into those networks.
Or even vulnerability
scanning to see
what's easy to be falling prey.
One of the things we
saw recently some time
back was when WordPress had some
vulnerabilities [INAUDIBLE].
We saw a lot of attacks from
Google targeting third party
WordPress sites,
or even other cloud
customers who had WordPress.
Those kind of
things are examples.
SWATI KULSHRESHTH: I
think one of the things we
see very frequently is that
your firewalls have not
been set up properly.
And then somebody manages
to get into your system
and start doing either
denial of service attacks,
or brute forcing, or any of the
other suspicious activities.
MARK MANDEL: I guess
that means if I'm
running my service on
Google Cloud Platform
and someone's hacked
me, then suddenly, I
don't have those resources on
that machine available to me
anymore if someone's
trying to mine bitcoins
or whatever it is the cool
kids are doing these days.
Suddenly, my CPU--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Those coins.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, exactly.
My CPU is suddenly at 100%.
And so I can't serve
traffic or do anything
I should be doing on my app.
EMEKA OKONKWO: Right.
And even, like you said,
it could be possible
that you could have
legitimate users who are
using the platform properly.
But because the
resources are being
used by these
irresponsible people,
or by people who have
been compromised,
they don't have the
ability to actually enjoy
what they paid for.
So that was a bad experience
for other customers
who are not doing abuse.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
most of the things
that we've discussed
so far are basically
people attacking or
somehow compromising
the account of someone
that is well-intentioned.
Does it also happen that
someone is well-intentioned
but somehow, they are not
aware of some limitations?
What kind of limitations
people sometimes forget?
SWATI KULSHRESHTH: I
think the biggest one
that we see in this
category is people
going outside of the
quota available to them
and using it multiple times.
So associated with
the free trial,
there are specific
quota limitations
in terms of number of projects,
in terms of how many emails
you can send, how much
network you can use.
And that is the one that people
often end up circumventing
and then getting caught
by one of the rules.
We do try to give a lot
of benefit of doubt.
So unless you're really
egregiously violating that,
we'll probably not
come after you.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
EMEKA OKONKWO: And
also, for example,
what we see as well, in addition
to what Swati had mentioned,
is that a lot of people
may not necessarily
take the precautions of
securing their instances
or set up the appropriate
firewalls to only allow
the traffic from the
designated VMs or instances.
So what happens is that
someone may basically
hack into their systems and
use their systems as a part
of a bot to do something bad.
So not taking the extra
couple of minutes required
to actually lock
down your machine
to make sure that you only get
traffic to and fro from what
you really want to has
been a lot of concern.
MARK MANDEL: You were
talking a little bit
as well just about
accidental stuff people do.
You talked a little
bit about projects.
So are there any
other sort of things
that people often go,
oh, it'll be fine,
or they don't even
realize that that
was a terms of service
thing that they go past,
that people should be aware of?
SWATI KULSHRESHTH:
The most frequent ones
is the quotas and the number
of projects and email quotas.
EMEKA OKONKWO: And also,
sometimes, some people
may use the platform
as a hosting provider
so that, basically, other
people can run off of them
as part of the services they
offer to their own customers.
So if they don't properly
monitor those customers
or check the traffic,
they could also
end up getting a violations
of our terms of services.
So for example, if they open
up their service to a host,
like upload images, some
of them may be malware,
which is now being served
from the cloud customer
to external people.
So again, that's
also a violation.
So it may be not
you specifically.
But the people that
you provide services to
could end up costing
you a violation.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
that makes sense.
Anywhere you've got a system
that has user-generated content
or anything like that, you
need to be very careful
about what content
they're putting up there
and what it's possible to
enable to do on your platform.
EMEKA OKONKWO: That's correct.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So let's imagine that at
some point, for some reason,
either because by mistake,
they didn't pay attention
to terms of service, or somebody
got hacked, I get an email.
And the email is
basically saying, hey,
we detected some fraudulent
activity in your account.
What's next?
What do I have to do?
SWATI KULSHRESHTH: So
I can take that one.
When we see
something suspicious,
we will send out an
email to you saying,
we're seeing this
suspicious activity.
Please check it.
Please get back to us.
Send an appeal.
And there will be a
three day warning period.
The thing you need
to keep in mind
is that this email goes
out to the project owners.
So definitely monitor
your project owner email.
We hear a lot of developers
coming back to us saying, hey,
I wasn't monitoring it.
So I didn't realize that
there's something going on.
MARK MANDEL: I've heard
stories about that.
I think that's a great takeaway.
I just want to highlight that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It's
happened to us, actually,
where we got an email from
our internal email, the Google
Glass Platform podcast, about
some certificate going away.
And we're like, whoops.
MARK MANDEL: We
somehow new about that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: OK.
That's a very important point.
Pay attention to the emails.
SWATI KULSHRESHTH: So
the process going forward
is you go to the
Developer console.
It will take you to
the Appeals page.
And you send an appeal.
The good thing to
do about the appeal
is to actually give us some
context around what you're
doing, what your
project is doing,
and why do you think that
suspicious activity might
be happening.
We definitely don't need
the code of your program.
We don't need a design diagram.
But we do need some context
to see why this was happening.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: How
much information do you
give out of this?
Will be something like, you're
going over the quota on this,
or you're using too much
CPU, or something like that?
Or it's just like, hey.
What kind of
information do I get?
SWATI KULSHRESHTH:
We definitely provide
information on what kind
of suspicious activity
we are seeing.
So we will tell
you, we are seeing
denial of service
attacks, or we're
seeing you circumventing quota.
We will give you the project ID,
the project name, and the time
on which that happened.
If you need more information,
you can definitely
write back to us.
And sometimes we
can help you out.
Sometimes, you need to go back
and look at your own traffic
logs and see what was
happening around that time.
MARK MANDEL: So it
sounds like I get
the email, which I'm monitoring
because I look at my emails.
And you give me
some information.
So it really sounds like
the first step is actually
for me to go and have
a look at my project
and see if I can work
out what's going wrong.
And maybe I need to lock
something down better,
or just stop doing something
that I probably shouldn't have
been doing in the first place.
SWATI KULSHRESHTH: That's right.
EMEKA OKONKWO: And also, we
surface the same notifications
in the Developer console.
So you can log into
your Developer console
and see the same information.
So at least you will
see a notification
next to your project
with some icon, something
which you can mouse over.
It gives you more information
about high level, hey,
we saw something wrong.
Can you please take a look?
It needs your attention.
So that's another
way that you also
get the information about
something going wrong.
SWATI KULSHRESHTH: To
add to what Emeka just
said, if you are on
the Developer console,
go look at the Dashboard
for your projects.
And you will definitely see.
If there's an
issue, you will see
that surfaced on the Dashboard.
MARK MANDEL: Now, I'm curious.
If I go looking-- maybe
I'm not that technical.
Or for whatever reason, I can't
work out what the issue is.
Can I come to you
and say, hey, look.
I'm stuck.
Can you give me some
extra information?
Is that a thing you will do?
EMEKA OKONKWO: Yes.
You can come and ask us
for more information.
There are certain things that
we can share or not share.
So to the extent
that we can, we will
provide as much information
as we can to help you.
But if you're not really sure
what's going on with your VM,
for example, normally, we would
recommend that you kind of do
a re-install just to make
sure that you wipe out
any person who may have
hacked into your machine.
MARK MANDEL: Provision your
machines with a script.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
That makes sense.
So could you share a little
bit out of your experience.
You've been working on
this for quite a while.
What is some cool anecdotes
of people that have
gone through the abuse process?
SWATI KULSHRESHTH: I
think the most common one
is I'm not doing anything.
I didn't do anything wrong.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
SWATI KULSHRESHTH: And
then when we talk to them,
and they'll go back,
look at the traffic logs.
And they'll say, oh yeah.
I see this activity.
It must have happened.
Because I'm using a
newly installed software,
or this application
must be doing it.
There are times when some people
have installed apps and not
even realized that those
apps are doing things
on their behalf, which is
getting them to violate
the terms of conditions.
And when you get
that email saying
you're violating the terms
of service or something
is wrong or suspicious is
happening, go check it.
You may not be doing it.
Someone else may be doing
it from your system.
EMEKA OKONKWO: Even to
add on to what she said,
sometimes we've let
people know, hey,
we detected xyz is
happening on your platform.
And then they come back
to us and say, oh no.
Nothing is going on wrong.
Everything is fine.
And then later on, we get
a report from a third party
also saying, hey, we got abusive
traffic from this person.
And so when we now
send it to them,
they're like, oh my goodness.
So something is wrong.
What's going on?
So usually when we do
say something is wrong,
try to take a look.
Because more likely than not,
there is something going on.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
And if you're not
able to find it, just
reply saying, hey,
I'm not able to find it.
Give me a hand.
EMEKA OKONKWO: Right.
MARK MANDEL: You made
an interesting point
there very quickly.
You work with third
parties as well
who also report, basically,
that traffic or something bad is
happening in particular places?
EMEKA OKONKWO: Yes.
That's correct.
So we also receive
reports from third parties
who are reporting attacks
that they receive coming
from the Google Cloud Platform.
So it's a part of our
duties, in addition
to protecting cloud customers,
is to also take that
into consideration.
Basically, if you
verify the report,
because not everybody
who tells you is-- maybe
they have some spiteful stuff.
But you have to verify
that it actually
is a legitimate report.
And if so, we also
act on those as well.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So what about when
people are hosting
content that is fraudulent?
So it's not really about
what you are doing,
but about what you're serving.
So for instance, let's
imagine some pirated movie
or stuff like that.
EMEKA OKONKWO: Well,
we all love movies.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, we do.
EMEKA OKONKWO: So
if someone is found
to be hosting some sort of movie
that is copyright protected,
or falls under the
DMCA act, what we
do when we receive such
reports is that we actually
work with our
legal team and send
those notifications to them.
Because that is not
necessarily abuse,
but it might be something that
falls under legal category.
So basically, our role in
that is just mostly forward
those to the legal team so that
they can move it from there.
MARK MANDEL: But that
would be a violation
of the terms of service.
EMEKA OKONKWO: It
would be a violation
of the terms of service.
Yes.
MARK MANDEL: Interesting.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
And at some point,
you mentioned that very often,
it's about vulnerabilities.
And sometimes it's applications
that are malicious, really.
But what about when
there is something
that all of a sudden
everybody knows about,
and all the internet
is unsafe again,
like Heartbleed, for instance.
EMEKA OKONKWO: In those
kind of situations,
when this had happened, we work
closely with the Cloud Security
Team to come up with
some solutions that
can help to protect
our customers
and like use that or deploy
that to help to protect them.
So we've had some situations,
like the Heartbleed one.
One that comes to mind
is one called Raw Hammer,
which was a big security issue.
And we worked with the
Cloud Security Team
to help us to come up with
appropriate mitigation
steps that can be applied
on the Cloud Platform.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Can
you explain a little bit
what Raw Hammer is?
I've never heard about it.
EMEKA OKONKWO: I
don't know what it is.
MARK MANDEL: We'll put a
link in the show notes.
We'll do some research.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
We'll find it.
That's an interesting one.
Cool.
MARK MANDEL: So that's cool.
All right.
Well, I think we should talk
about DocGraph, I think.
It's the elephant in the room.
We should probably
talk about it.
If anyone hasn't heard about
it, it was [INAUDIBLE].
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
Very interesting story.
Basically, it went
crazy on hacker news.
Someone said, oh yeah, Google
Cloud basically shut down
my company completely.
And I think it's interesting
because it was shut down
by Cloud Abuse, your team.
So let's talk about that.
What happened?
Could you tell us a little
bit about the internals, what
did actually happen in there?
EMEKA OKONKWO: Yeah.
So what happened was
that we had actually
received some third party
reports about attacks
coming from the user's machine.
And after we independently
verified the situation,
we sent the user a
notification, which
comes with a grace period.
And so the user did
receive the notification.
But it seems that there were
some problems on the Developer
console which prevented
the user from being
able to submit a successful
appeal within the time period
that he had.
And so unfortunately, after
the time period had expired,
he actually had his
project suspended.
And so that's when
he wrote the email.
MARK MANDEL: Now, it sounds
like there was some reach out
from the Google Cloud Team,
and the Cloud Abuse Team
worked with him.
So we ended up getting
the project reinstated?
EMEKA OKONKWO: That's correct.
SWATI KULSHRESHTH: Yes.
MARK MANDEL: And
we've been working,
I believe, with him as
well to add to improvements
and basically improve things
that went wrong before.
Can you talk a little
about those as well?
SWATI KULSHRESHTH: Yes.
So that issue actually
highlighted a few things
that had been happening
or that were not great
as far as the developer
experience was concerned.
And when this issue
highlighted those,
we've been working
hard to fix them.
We've made a few
changes to the way
we inform developers on the
email, as well as the Developer
console, so that they
have more information
to take corrective steps.
Our team worked really
hard to fix those issues.
And those were fixed within a
week of this issue happening.
EMEKA OKONKWO: Right.
So basically, it was the
detection was correct.
The issue was correct.
But we didn't have a
good enough experience
from a developer's
standpoint for them
to communicate and
reach out to us.
That doesn't always happen.
It was a unique set
of circumstances
that happened for him.
Because we do get people who
are able to successfully appeal.
But kind of like when
something goes wrong,
everything goes wrong
kind of situation.
So that's actually what
happened in his situation.
MARK MANDEL: I'm
super happy to say
that he has said, "I'm very
pleased with the service
overall and will likely remain
a customer for a long time."
So very happy to hear that
the resolution has made
a deep and meaningful impact.
So super happy about that.
Cool.
Well, in case we
missed anything,
I need to ask our
standard question.
Is there anything else you want
to talk about or highlight,
or maybe new things?
Or anything we
might have missed?
EMEKA OKONKWO: We have a
couple of Help Center articles
that basically give
you some explanations
about some of the policy
violations and also steps
of how you can
secure your instance.
So as we see a lot of times,
people are compromised.
So if you can take
a look at those,
that will really help you out.
Prevention is better
than cure, right?
MARK MANDEL: Absolutely.
SWATI KULSHRESHTH: Our
emails will direct you
to those articles.
So if it is about
just figuring out
how to get through
this process, we
have a Help Center
article on that.
We have Help Center articles
on specific abuse types
that we will be sending
you emails about.
We're also trying to
proactively reach out to you.
Because one of the things
that we've been talking about,
a common theme, is the
instance has been compromised.
So we're trying to reach out to
developers whose instances we
see could be at a high
risk of being compromised
before the compromise happens.
So keep watching out
for those emails.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
We'll have the links
to those articles
directly from the
show notes here.
So I would say that then, one
of the biggest pieces of advice
is pay attention to your emails.
SWATI KULSHRESHTH: Yes.
EMEKA OKONKWO: Or
to the dashboard.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
To the dashboard.
What could be the second biggest
piece of advice for someone
that wants to make
sure that they're
going to get impacted by fraud?
EMEKA OKONKWO: I would say make
sure your instances are secure.
Check your firewalls.
A lot of times, everything
is open to everybody.
So it may be easier
to get started
faster, which is awesome.
But do take the extra time
to actually lock things down.
SWATI KULSHRESHTH:
I think to add
to that, the third one is a lot
of times, the software you've
installed on your
instance, just make
sure all the security
patches are in place
and keep on top of that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
So basically, just
make sure no one else gets
to use your resources.
SWATI KULSHRESHTH: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
Well, thank you so much
for taking the time
to talk to us about
abuse yesterday.
EMEKA OKONKWO: You're welcome.
Thank you so much
for inviting us.
MARK MANDEL: Thank you.
Thanks for joining us
today, Swati and Emeka.
Super interesting discussion.
And I definitely learned a
lot about the abuse process,
and why it exists, and why I
think it's really so important.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
I think that the
most important thing
was Abuse is here only because
we need to protect you too,
which is really interesting.
And how most of the
time, when Abuse
is dealing with customers,
it's because they
might have been compromised.
So take care.
Make sure that your network
is correctly configured
and you have all your networking
firewall rules and all
that stuff set correctly.
Which, by the way,
that's what we will
be talking about next episode.
So maybe that's
what we should do.
Listen to the next
episode next week.
But I think now,
it's time to go talk
about the question of the week.
And the question of
the week is something
that I really like because
I'm a pretty lazy person.
And sometimes I see very
often examples of this
is how you run
Jenkins on Kubernetes,
or this is how you run Drupal
or WordPress on Kubernetes,
whatever.
And it really make me feel,
well, on Google Cloud Platform,
we have this really
cool thing, which
is Deployment Manager, that you
can easily click on a button
and then you get a deployment.
Boom.
Done.
Easy.
Is there such a
thing for Kubernetes?
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
So this is really cool.
If anyone's tracked
along with what
was Deploy Manager,
and then Helm,
and then backwards and
forwards, everything
got sort of consolidated
recently, which is really cool.
Everything's now in
Helm for Kubernetes.
So Helm is this
thing that lets you
deploy common things, like
applications, to Kubernetes.
So some things that
are supported right now
in the stable are Drupal,
Jenkins, WordPress, stuff
like that.
So if you've used
Apt Get, or you've
used Yum, or other
package managers,
such as maybe NPM
or Gem or something
like that to start a--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Or Yarn.
MARK MANDEL: I've
never used Yarn.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It just
was announced today.
MARK MANDEL: OK.
Cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That's why.
MARK MANDEL: Then you can
use that to deploy stuff
to Kubernetes.
There is a command line client.
What it does is it says
Helm is the command line
client and charts
what the packages are
called within Helm.
And then you can
search through it.
You can initialize.
You can go Helm Install.
And that builds
stuff up and puts it
into Kubernetes for you,
which is super cool.
There's currently
two repositories.
There's the stable repository.
And then there's the
incubating repository,
which has some stuff that's
almost there, but not quite
there yet, which includes
things like HCD and Console
and MongoDB, and a few
other things as well.
But I think this is super
cool and very exciting
for people who just
want to get stuff up
and running on Kubernetes,
especially if it's common stuff
that everyone's already doing.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
I think that is a very
nice way, especially also,
not only if you are the one
consuming those packages,
but if you have a
cool application
and you want to distribute
it in an easy way.
Anyone can go just
run this command
and get started trying it.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, absolutely.
Excellent.
All right.
Well, Fransesc, are you
up to anything interesting
in the next few weeks?
Where you off to?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So I'm
going to be rerecording
some of the episodes
just for fun
because we've been having
some technical issues.
But I should be releasing
some of those very soon.
And other than that,
I will go next month.
I will be in Brazil
for GopherCon Brasil.
Very excited about that.
My talk starts to take
shape, which is nice.
We're three weeks
away, so it is good.
And then also, at GCP
Next Brasil-- which,
by the way, if you
are interested,
we are going to be running
our GCP Next conference, so
Google Cloud Platform Next.
You are going to be learning
about what we're working on
and what are the new things.
And this time, it's going to
be in Brazil in Sao Paolo.
So November 10 in Sao Paulo,
if you're somewhere around.
We will have a link to
that so you can register.
It's going to be lots of fun.
There's going to be a lot
of people from my team
and all the teams from
Google Cloud Platform there.
So come say hi.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
That sounds fantastic.
Well, when this comes
out, next week after that,
I will be back in Atlanta
again for a web conference
called Connect Tech.
And then the week
after that, I will
be in Atlantic City for
another game development
conference, Gamer Con.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
Atlanta again.
You really like to go
to the same city twice
or three times in a row.
MARK MANDEL: I try.
I try and do that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
You know, you can
also stay there.
MARK MANDEL: I could.
You're right.
No.
I think I like going
there and coming back.
I think it's just
something I like to do.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I'll miss
you too much otherwise.
MARK MANDEL: Exactly.
All right, Fransesc.
Well, thank you so
much for joining me
for yet another week.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Thank you.
And talk to you and
you all next week.
MARK MANDEL: See you next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]